arnaud montebourg est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir soi et merci
d'être avec nous au chantre de la
démondialisation durant la campagne de
la primaire socialiste vous parcourez la
france depuis quelques semaines la
france de la désindustrialisation pour
françois hollande
l'emploi est bien sûr au coeur des
préoccupations des français qui se
disent par ailleurs déçu un parent par
la tournure actuelle de la campagne
présidentielle nous aborderons ces
sujets tout à l'heure avec samir tounsi
de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire et puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat lui succédera
et nous parlerons du printemps des
poètes un aragon la rose et le réséda
qui vous inspirent pour votre mouvement
arnaud montebourg d'abord est-ce que
vous avez obtenu des informations de la
police ou de la justice
après l'agression dont vous avez été
victime l'autre soir dans les rues de
paris avec votre compagne oui d'abord je
veux remercier les forces de l'ordre de
prendre très au sérieux cette enquête
judiciaire la police judiciaire m'a
montré la vidéo surveillance qui avait
enregistré l'ensemble des faits et
contrairement aux insinuations que je
lis parfois ici ou là où finalement nous
aurions monté en épingle et amplifier un
incident qui n'aurait pas été grave ou
qui auraient été sans importance ou sans
conséquence toutes les déclarations que
j'ai pu faire ainsi que dre pulvar sur
procès-verbal la police judiciaire sont
parfaitement confirmé l'agression est
parfaitement démontré dans la façon dont
la caméra de vidéosurveillance a filmé
la scène la question c'est le lien avec
le front national est ce qu'il est
établi
écoutez je en dehors des insultes
raciales antisémites des violences
volontaires jet de verre deux verres
nous avons essuyé je n'y peux rien si
ces militants scandaient le nom de
l'open président donc il ya bien un
militantisme un engagement politique une
présentation d'un soutien à l'un des
candidats général gilles favorisée par
marine le pen selon vos le climat
général de la libération de la parole
raciste est un problème dans notre pays
ça se voit déjà sur les matchs de foot
pas seulement professionnels mais aussi
amateurs mais là nous avons une scène de
rue qui rappelait les heures sombres
histoires avec l'allusion au
qu'il faudrait chassés de france le mot
juden qui a été crié des insultes de
nature comme les graisses ou montebourg
va mettre tes babouche parce que mes
origines algériennes sont connus donc
nous avons affaire à des militants
politiques connaissent ils sont qu'ils
nous ont reconnus les militants
politiques donc vos maîtres des
militants politiques et cela et c'est
effectivement ils sont identifiés je
fais confiance maintenant à la polygynie
si on les voit à visage découvert sur
les vidéos je fais confiance à la police
judiciaire pour procéder à
l'identification des coupables et de
l'interpellation prochaine je l'espère
peut-elle se doit être proche je le
souhaite pour le souhaitez marine le pen
justement il a donc lancé le débat sur
la viande halal elle est suivie par le
président candidat pour qui c'est le
premier sujet de préoccupation des
français il l'a dit est ce que vous
diriez à titre personnel comme françois
fillon que l'abattage rituel ne
correspond à plus grand chose dans le
monde moderne
écoutez faire la question de savoir si
l'étourdissement des animaux avant leur
abattage leur consommation est une
préoccupation majeure de la france me
paraît être une manoeuvre grossière et
grotesque de diversion par rapport aux
problèmes considérables qu'aujourd'hui
les français rencontrent leur vie
quotidienne
nous avons perdu sept cent cinquante
mille emplois industriels sur le
territoire en plus fait un tour comment
je fais un tour de france oui je fais un
tour de france de la désolation des
industriels de la viande halal nous
avons perdu 900 usine en trois ans qui
ont fermé dans notre pays et vous avez
un président de la république qui refuse
de faire la moindre proposition de
stratégie de sortie de crise et qui
préfèrent amuser la galerie avec des
histoires des tours 10
d'agneau et de moutons qui je le
rappelle relève de rites religieux qui
ne regarde pas l'état l'état a pour
mission de garantir la liberté de
l'exercice des cultes
c'est ça le sens du principe de laïcité
que françois hollande souhaite inscrire
dans la constitution c'est une de ses
propositions pour qu' il n'y ait pas
d'ingérence dans l'exercice des cultes
chacun a sa religion les mormons les
couacs heures les adventistes et
protestants les bouddhistes les juifs
les chrétiens les catholiques les
protestants
peu importe les musulmans peu importe
ils ont le droit de vivre tranquillement
dans la sphère privée
conformément à leurs rites et l'état
doit assurer le vivre ensemble car nous
sommes un des seuls pays occidentaux au
monde à avoir 5 millions de personnes se
rattachant la culture musulmane et 5
millions c'est beaucoup
donc nous avons la république garantit
la liberté mais recule et la
non-ingérence et on se débat créé un
certain malaise au sein de la majorité
il ya beaucoup de deux voix qui
s'élèvent au sein même de l'ump vous
pensez que nicolas sarkozy donc à fait
fausse route
d'abord je crois que le premier devrait
retirer ses propos parce que cela ne
relève pas de sa mission que de dire ce
qui est bon ou mauvais dans les rites
religieux ma fille c'est comme si on
jouait à titre personnel mais il
n'accorde expression personnelle il est
le premier ministre de la france comme
une chef du gouvernement au président
candidat
je crois que ce n'est pas la première
préoccupation des français d'autant que
la semaine d'avant il est allé à rungis
pour expliquer qu'il ya aucun problème
donc emmanuel todd que vous appréciez
j'imagine un jeu sociologues géographes
il estime qu'il y a deux candidats
d'extrême droite en france dont 1
soutenue par l'allemagne
ce qu'il va trop loin dans son
appréciation des choses je crois qu'il a
un raccourci qui résume finalement assez
bien la situation c'est que la course
que nicolas sarkozy est en train de
faire derrière madame le pen fait que
finalement madame le pen est la
directrice de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy elle fixe les thèmes fixé
jacinda les questions et monsieur
sarkozy se précipitent
car ils cherchent aujourd'hui à occuper
l'espace peut-être laissé vacant dans
quelques jours par madame le pen si elle
n'a pas signé dans cette ville mise sur
l'absence de marine le pen sur
l'opération sur le terrain
1 la pression des dirigeants de l'ump
est considérable pour empêcher les
maires qui traditionnellement donné leur
signature à madame le pen de le faire ah
oui et par exemple un bon faudrait
quelques exemples ah oui est ce qu'il
faudrait donc un geste des élus des
maires socialistes par exemple pour
permettre je voudrais d'abord vous dire
pourquoi madame le pen risque n'avoir
pas ses signatures à cause d'elle même
car elle a sur son flanc droit car là
une extrême droite derrière derrière
l'extrême droite madame le pen y ait une
autre extrême droite car le grand cul
dur monsieur carl lang qui est déjà
quelques 400 signatures lui le directeur
de campagne de son père jean marie le
pen qui a stérilisé 380 signatures pour
empêcher madame le pen de se présenter
ils ont décidé en interne d'abattre
marine de valeurs mobilières et materne
avait annoncé que madame le pen ne
rassemble pas son camp ce que son père
réussissait à faire et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les guérillas
entre faction d'extrême droite
aujourd'hui qui sévissent sur le
territoire français est au tour de
madame le pen a pour conséquence que
madame le pen risque par son incapacité
à faire ce que son père réussissez à
faire de grands progrès par les
pressions de l'ump sur ces maires pour
qu'ils n'y a pas de signature alors ce
serait une telle déflagration l'absence
de marine le pen un par la compétition
présidentielle arnaud montebourg vaudois
il faudrait t'il que les maires
socialistes donnent leurs parrainages
nous ne sommes pas la roue de secours de
l'extrémisme que madame le pen rassemble
son camp il soit capable finalement de
retrouver les signatures que son père
avait cessé sa tâche mais elle n'en est
pas capable et c'est la raison de son
propre échec
autre sujet en gala merkel en soutenant
nicolas sarkozy rend elle selon vous ce
service à françois hollande
le pacte le fameux pacte des dirigeants
conservateurs européens a été démentie
est ce que savait pas finalement cette
hypothèse cette rumeur lancée par le chp
eagle ou cette information une aubaine
pour le candidat que vous soutenez
d'abord que le groupe des conservateurs
de l'union européenne décide de se
coaliser contre finalement les
propositions de françois hollande de
renégociation du traité punitifs sur la
question budgétaire c'est-à-dire le
traité osterrieth r1
vous avez une droit de brit air oui vous
avez une droite européenne de
l'austérité vous avez une gauche
européenne de la croissance et c'est ce
refus parce que la croissance se décrète
pas retraités à c'est une stratégie
économique que refuse d'accepter madame
merkel
c'est tout le débat d'ailleurs entre la
droite et la gauche allemande nous avons
signé un texte avec le spd allemand nous
parti socialiste français qui propose un
autre chemin une autre alternative
notamment la remontée des salaires en
allemagne des salaires minima qui
n'existe pas il n'y a pas de smic en
allemagne également les normes sociales
minimales sur les prestations sociales
assurance maladie retraite santé dans
tous les pays négociations on est
d'accord du traité c'est ce qu'a proposé
françois oui mais vous voyez bien
apprécié les droites européennes veulent
empêcher une gauche de réussir dans un
des pays qui est quand même l'un des
fondateurs est un défi majeur de l'union
européenne oui il y a là une atteinte à
la liberté d'expression des français qui
doivent pouvoir choisir leur avenir avec
leurs orientations politiques vont
rester et que françois hollande ne soit
pas reçu ni par angela merkel ni jeune
fille de carole je ne blâme à les
droites européennes lors de soutenir le
candidat de droite en france puisque
comme cela nous pourrons nous autour je
l'espère la victoire en irlande rallier
l'ensemble des gauches européennes il
faire se lever les peuples contre les
politiques de l'ensemble de sa grille
gens à droite vous avez parlé des
sociaux démocrates allemands comme les
travaillistes britanniques ils ont été
très surpris par la proposition de
françois hollande de taxer à hauteur de
75%
les très riches pas vous j'ai une alors
est donc ce sera pas de quartier
attendait alors pour ne pas l'avoir jour
là pas besoin à la fois ce sont les
patrons du cac 40 comme pour les
footballeurs d'abord ils viendront parce
que c'est particulièrement injuste que
finalement
l'ultra minorité d'ultra riches qui a
fait fortune pendant la crise sur les
décombres de la misère des autres ne se
participent pas à l'effort de
restauration des finances publiques
mêmes problèmes de flux actifs
françois hollande a reconnu que ça ne
m'avait pas faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses de l'état c'est
toujours ça de pris ça de moins que un
peureux et elle a parlé d'un exemple
patriotique mais c'est nécessaire qu'il
y ait des exemples patriotique et j'ai
envie de vous dire dans le segment pl
dans la lah
l'histoire des états unis d'amérique qui
dirait eu des taux beaucoup plus élevé
je crois 80% à l'époque du président
roosevelt on le sait toujours nager
c'est est le l'emblème de ma campagne
des primeurs je sais lire l'histoire y
avait pas mal d'exemples si on à
l'époque paraît-il oui mais c'était
nécessaire parce que il s'agissait de
rétablir les comptes publics prises pour
retenir les riches en france mais qui va
payer à leur place d'abord les riches
n'est pas du mois ils auront le devoir
de respecter leur patrie tu as comme
sont le mas ports français partent déjà
il les dossiers se constituer par
exemple aujourd'hui dans les cabinets
mieux suivre dior mais monsieur
grossiord s'ils veulent partir qu'il
parte mais qui paient leur place mais
s'ils veulent partir qu'il parte mais
nous leur demanderons des comptes car on
reste français ça s'appelle l'évasion
fiscale vous pensez que nous allons
rester inerte devant les évadés fiscaux
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire si vous
pensez que à baisser l'impôt fait
revenir les riches qui étaient là
fragile monsieur sarkozy vous vous
mettez le doigt riante et ça les fait
partir seul je vais vous dire où est
passé monsieur johnny halliday qui avait
dit grâce à nicolas sarkozy je vais
rentrer en france
il est toujours à gstaad en suisse
considéré comme un évadé fiscal et il
n'a fait l'objet d'aucune inquiétude de
la part des services fiscaux
je voudrais que monsieur
johnny hallyday rentrer même si les
impôts sont plus élevées car il pourrait
montrer accueil il aime son pays est ce
que c'est une mesure symbole patriotique
donc pour reprendre le mot de françois
hollande
destiné à mieux faire passer
l'augmentation des impôts qui va frapper
tous les français demain je vous pose la
question
arnaud montebourg parce que vous par
exemple en saône et loire vous avez su
convaincre les habitants qu'il fallait
augmenter les impôts
ben je suis les convaincre et surtout
montré que ça vous l'avez vu un tollé
car si nous voulions avoir un minimum de
solidarité notamment sur la dépendance
il était normal que cet effort soit
demandé quand est ce qu'il faut dire aux
français aussi
mais c'est ce qu'a dit françois hollande
il a exposé dans son discours je crois
de dijon mais qu'il était nécessaire que
la dépendance la dépendance indépendance
et le soient financées par la solidarité
donc par un prélèvement
pourquoi c'est normal dès lors qu'il ya
un effort de solidarité supplémentaire
qu'on demande un effort supplémentaire à
tous surtout pour les millions de
familles qui sont aujourd'hui dans
l'angoissé ne concerne pas ça la
dépendance vous le savez bien c'est un
commencement de la retraite à 60 ans
pour ceux qui pourront pas retirer là
aussi cela aussi le plan est financé
il n'y aura pas d'effort sociales
supplémentaires sans effort fiscal
complémentaire
c'est normal mais il suffit de le dire
de le clarifier c'est le cas et surtout
je crois que les français sont prêts à
ça dès lors qu'il ya un plus pour eux
les normal qu'ils participent à cet
effort commun ce qui serait injuste ce
serait de faire payer le prix de la
crise les dettes accumulées par le
sarkozysme qui sont himalayenne par les
classes populaires
là pour le coup je bon excusez moi je me
défends parce que vous mmes empêché de
terminer mes phrases mais s'agissant de
duperie de la crise et de la dette
c'est la taxation sur les transactions
financières une recette de 200 milliards
au plan européen qui nous permettra de
rembourser très facilement le prix de ce
qu'a coûté les plans de sauvetage et de
renflouement daglan et pas répondre ne
fait pas la différence entre les patrons
du cac 40 qui sont effectivement enrichi
puisque leur rémunération a fortement
progressé
et puis les footballeurs non non lieu
d'ailleurs quel problème pour le
football les clubs s'adapte alors
qu'ailleurs on peut demander à monsieur
anelka qui gagnent de 140000 euros par
semaine dans un club de chine
aimer son pays aussi comme vous et moi
peut-être oui ce n'est pas excessif que
lui demander ça et bien comme il aime
son pays qui parlent une langue
française châtié 1 qu'il respecte les
couleurs qu'ils chantent la marseillaise
sur les terrains les pelouse
eh bien il paiera plus d'impôts voilà je
le lui annonce avec d'autres socialistes
et ce sera un grand bien pour la patrie
mais voit bien que lui et tous les
autres en short
un soir une photo la halle et samir
tounsi de l' agence france-presse à nous
rejoindre mais avant cela arnaud
montebourg on va donc vous suivre dans
ce tour de france
hélas de la désindustrialisation vous
étiez d'ailleurs en côte de rier auprès
des salariés du laboratoire fournier
dont canon parrot par le grand
laboratoire américain leur emploi est
menacé alors que le groupe américain se
régaleront creux bien on vous a vu aussi
auprès des lejaby mais coiffé sur le
poteau d'un par nicolas sarkozy
notamment yssingeaux mais il ya d'autres
unités
ce fabricant de lingerie en france
sandra cerqueira des parties toujours
sur la route arnaud montebourg candidat
à la primaire socialiste il sillonnait
déjà l'hexagone avec sa caravane
aujourd'hui il est mandaté par françois
hollande pour effectuer un tour de
france des usines qui souffrent c'est
ainsi qu'il a trouvé sa place dans la
campagne
un déplacement par semaine avec à chaque
fois le même message défendre le made in
france défendre aussi son candidat car
le sort des ouvriers en lutte est au
coeur de la présidentielle et il était
un petit instrument dans leurs caisses
que dirige françois hollande je vais pas
tu dois peut-être pas un piccolo
médisants une flûte traversière le gros
de la mélodie et quand même joué par des
gens comme michel sapin comme manuel
valls comme pierre moscovici qui sont
les dirigeants principaux de la campagne
de françois hollande et qui eux entonne
le refrain de la rigueur de gauche à
porter la bonne parole de françois
hollande est une chose trouver des
repreneurs en est une autre
surtout quand l'ump jouent la
concurrence à yssingeaux laurent
wauquiez devance arnaud montebourg un
échec pour le ps
un mois plus tard c'est l'acte 2 et le
vainqueur cette fois c'est lui
il réussit le sauvetage du site le geig
de bourg-en-bresse et d'une cinquantaine
de salariés la repreneuse assia hiridjee
refuse d'entrer dans des considérations
politiques et se contentent d'assurer
que tout a été fait pour qu'elle ne
baisse pas les bras
il ya des jours où c'était j'étais un
peu découragé ses coûts y arrivera
jamais mais il a été au quotidien au
quotidien il a été présent il me disait
toujours mais non vous allez voir assia
vous y arriverez vous y arriverez en on
retrouvera une usine
vous ferez votre projet votre
fabrication française
les syndicats déplorent de ne pas avoir
été associé à ce qu'ils appellent une
reprise politique
une reprise qui permet à arnaud
montebourg de peaufiner son rôle de
monsieur économie de françois hollande
peut être de futurs minutes
voilà ça me reconnaissez de l' agence
france presse nous a rejoint dans sa
mire première question laurent wauquiez
autour des soutes des sites industriels
en difficulté il faut garder un peu osé
non d'abord ne fait pas la course et les
marches je pense je considère que la
désindustrialisation la
réindustrialisation ne paie est une
cause nationale et que nous aurons
besoin de tout le monde donc si monsieur
o qui a des solutions surtout pour une
usine qui se trouve à 800 m de ses
bureaux qu'il n'avait jamais été visités
j'étais le premier envoyé par françois
hollande pour voir ces ouvrières qui
scandaient fabriqué en france avec leur
hymne l'hymne des symboles victimes de
la mondialisation en france ces femmes
qui avaient travaillé toute leur vie
payés au smic qu'on jetait comme ça sans
personne ne s'en occupe
il y avait là une raison bouleversé la
france parce qu'il y avait là une
violence inhumaine
c'est eren la solution de reprise qui
était je loupé la cgt qui a déclaré que
la solution était solide
je leur fais confiance de même que la
main il s'agit de faire confiance aux
repreneurs fournisseurs de l verges
moi je crois que sur le terrain ça
fonctionne d'autant mieux je m'en
réjouis
tant mieux tant mieux tant mieux il ya
encore trois sites lejaby a le ce thème
et des solutions elles gardent rieu est
ce qu'il ya des solutions on vient sans
trouver une pour bourque la stratégie de
made in france de madame massiat érigé
qui est une ancienne créatrice de
princesse tam tam et qui a inventé une
nouvelle marque made in france monette
et l'hommage doit lui être rendus car
elle a décidé de reconquérir le textile
français dans la lingerie qui a été
complètement décimée par l'entrée sans
contrepartie ni condition de la chine
dans l'organisation mondiale du commerce
et son arrivée sur le marché européen a
détruit des centaines de milliers
d'emplois et partout dans nos
territoires dans nos régions
vous voyez des petites unités de 20
2 30 qui disparaissent sans que personne
s'en occupe eh bien ma la mairie j'ai
décidé de remonter des petites unités
donc j'espère qu'elle va réussir un et
qu'elle pourrait en créer d'autres
j'espère aussi pour les anciennes
ouvrières de lejaby qu'elles
retrouveront du travail les
mécaniciennes audois de vous avez des
nouvelles lejaby en tunisie elle gagne
un peu plus de 200 euros par mois
elles se disent combler très heureuse
comme jamais certes mais un nous avons
une france qui est en chute libre sur le
plan industriel avec une zone rouge
un pays qui ne produit plus est dans la
main de pays qui eux continuent à
produire
je n'ai pas envie que la france
ressemble un magnifique musée avec
littoral disneyland et des stations de
ski
un fantastique hotel resort and spa 1
nous méritons mieux alors on sent que
vous êtes très à l'aise dans ce tour de
france de d1 de désindustrialisation je
suis malheureux de voir ce que je
constate
mais vous avez entendu dans le reportage
ce proche de jean luc mélenchon qui dit
que vous êtes dans leurs caisses de
françois hollande
une flûte traversière qui j'aurai une
petite musique de gauche par rapport aux
grosses caisses de la rigueur de gauche
est-ce que ce que vous avez l'impression
que c'est le rapport actuel de force
qu'il ya le rapport de force actuel
qu'il ya dans l'équipe de françois
hollande
ben je ne crois pas parce que le
discours de françois hollande les
orientations de campagne sont le fruit
d'un accord politique entre lui même et
les propositions que j'ai faites visant
d'ailleurs à contraindre les excès de la
finance a engagé un mouvement de
relocalisation sur le territoire qui est
une des composantes de ma
démondialisation qui n'est pas la mienne
déjà mais qui est un mouvement d'idées
qui a beaucoup progressé dans les têtes
en france
d'ailleurs j'étais hier à nancy où
françois hollande m'a demandé de parler
juste avant lui c'était un honneur
reprenant lui-même la parole derrière
moi les discours étaient assez
semblables donc nous voyons bien qu'il y
a je crois un centre de gravité de la
campagne de françois hollande qui est au
coeur de toutes les gauches et de
l'ensemble des gauches et de leur
sensibilité alliés beaucoup plus loin
dans votre campagne dans votre propre
campagne en septembre ou au quiz
aujourd'hui de la mise sous tutelle des
banques
quid de la démondialisation nous avons
tout de même un candidat qui est pour
pour le livre est champion du
protectionnisme ce truc du procès
qu'ils s'appellent a démandé je pense
que vous n'avez pas lu le programme de
françois hollande
je vous lis très gentiment il ya des
propositions visant à protéger contre la
concurrence déloyale une ancienne
programme que j'ai lu comme vous ou vous
vous avez été vous avez pu tenir là mais
c'est ce que je suis en train de vous
dire d'abord un mouvement de
relocalisation en rappelant les
entreprises françaises à leurs
obligations patriotique exactement ce
que fait monsieur obama en amérique du
nord
ce que fait madame rousseff au brésil
mal à mme kirchner
au brésil c'est à dire où on utilise la
fiscalité les marchés publics la
commande publique
les taxes sur les produits déloyaux la
taxe carbone extérieure par exemple et
beaucoup d'autres leviers qui sont entre
les mains des états pour nous protéger
contre la concurrence déloyale
extra-européenne extérieurs à l'union
européenne un mouvement de
relocalisation ça veut dire qu'on va
convoquer les multinationales on va leur
demander de relocaliser leurs activités
sur le territoire national quand elle
souhaite fabriquer pour la france à se
poser une question à la mode dans cette
campagne je ne vous ai pas encore
entendu répondre qu'est ce que vous
préférez une usine renault où une usine
d'une marque française à l'étranger où
une usine toyota ou de marques
étrangères qui ouvre en france je veux
les deux mon capitaine
c'est un peu facile comme ben c'est pas
facile parce que la stratégie low cost
qui a choisi monsieur carlos ghosn est
une grave erreur car à force de vouloir
diminuer les coûts vous finissez par
détruire votre outil industriel national
et la marque au losange est aujourd'hui
la seule marque française avec seulement
30 % de composants fabriqués en france
donc vous êtes en train peut-être de
sauver trop temporairement ou
provisoirement la trésorerie de renault
mais en vérité vous avez détruit toute
votre base industrielle donc vous êtes
une sorte d' usine offshore qui va
vendre des voitures comme des petits
pains loccoz pas cher et qui vont être
concurrencé par des pays encore plus
émergents qui auront des coûts encore
plus bas sur des technologies totalement
banal donc c'est pour moi une stratégie
suicidaire pour la fin de renault c'est
ça la crainte que nous avons donc je
propose la stratégie je préfère la
stratégie de peugeot qui elle fabrique a
maintenu son outil industriel sa base
industrielle en france essaie de
remonter dans la gamme plutôt que de
descendre toujours
d'augmenter en innovation en créativité
chercher des alliances comme general
motors pour mutualiser les coûts de
création du doigt par les syndicats
s'inquiètent ils ont raison peut-être
encore ils ont raison de s'inquiéter
il faudra être à leurs côtés pour
manifester cette inquiétude est fait en
sorte que cette affaire n'ait pas de
conséquences sur la destruction éventuel
d'emploi sur notre territoire
c'est très bien de vouloir attirer
l'attention de braquer l'attention sur
les licenciements boursiers mais vous
savez que la preuve le connaît c'est la
première cause d'inscription à pôle
emploi c'est la fin des cdd et des
contrats d'intérim
normalement les licenciements boursiers
selon le figaro ce matin ses 2 9% alors
que les les fins de cdd et d'intérim
c'est un tiers des inscriptions à pôle
emploi
voilà est-ce que quelques que faire pour
lutter contre cette équipe récaté
précarité pas avoir une approche
statistique du chômage parce que pour
moi un chômeur et vaut un autre show
bien sûr donc tous les chômeurs qui
aurait pu voir leurs emplois maintenus
doivent être on doit à tout prix par les
moyens de la puissance publique éviter
qu'ils le deviennent chômeurs donc je
vais pas faire une arithmétique delà du
chômage et de la douleur
comparées pour moi quand il ya des
emplois qu'on peut préserver parce que
l'entreprise gagne de l'argent il faut
les préserver on a déjà perdu dans la
crise toutes les entreprises qui
faisaient faillite parce qu'elles
gagnaient plus d'argent et qu'elle on
perdait mais maintenant on ferme des
entreprises qui en gagnent alors qu'est
ce qui va nous rester finalement il faut
l'interdire ça c'est pas que vous avez
besoin urgent à terre vous voulez quand
vous voulez annoncer les mesures
draconiennes et mais je vous explique
pourquoi c'est déjà interdit dans la loi
aujourd'hui un licenciement qui n'a pas
de cause réelle et sérieuse sur plat
économique est interdite le problème
c'est qu'il intervient quand les
licenciements a qu'un lieu que la
personne est déjà sur leurs droits
ce serait d'anticiper et de les
interdire d'interdire les escales 10 ans
des deux causes qui ont décidé d'eux
cour d'appel la cour d'appel de paris
qu'on appelle de reims qui ont décidé de
permettre aux organisations
représentatives du personnel de
suspendre quand manifestement
l'entreprise gagne de l'argent
voilà on a selon la décision de la cour
de cassation été reportée de quelques
jours sur ce sujet j'ai parlé hier vous
ai parlé hier
de dirigisme en tout cas très récemment
vous avez parlé de dirigisme alors après
le protectionnisme le dit le dirigisme
là aussi qu'est ce que c'est
concrètement ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire en 2012
on a vu un état qui étaient incapables
d'empêcher les fermetures de deux grands
mais il a été incapable parce qu'il ce
pourquoi il a été incapable
parce qu'on a vendu l'acier d'arcelor
qui appartenait aux européens
particulièrement la france à mittal dans
le centre qu'est ce que cela veut dire
le dirigeant des fans jamais joué à
londres si vous me laissez répond à sa
à 12 h et après 3 pour la question
est ce que je peux répondre à laisser
aller un gérant votre question par la
réponse quand même le temps c'est que je
les sais pas expliquer et vous me
reposez la même question alors c'est
très simple qu'est ce que les quels sont
les pays qui aujourd'hui ont réussi à
survivre dans la crise qui ne se sont
pas écroulés comme la france en train de
s'écrouler
c'est intéressant d'observer ces ceux
qui ont fusionné les intérêts publics et
les ambitions privé les intérêts privés
les intérêts publics et se sont associés
pour les faire vivre qui ont utilisé
leur monnaie une contrôler les
frontières limiter la circulation des
capitaux
organiser des protections données
d'aider des déductions fiscales
utilisez la commande publique pour
favoriser telle entreprise dresser à
lire mais ce que font tous les pays qui
aujourd'hui ont décidé de faire de la
politique économique et industrielle
voilà est ce que les européens lui faire
de manière sauf l'allemagne et les
italiens un peu c'est les pays qui ont
le mieux résisté sert ceux qui n'ont pas
adopté le modèle libéral financier tout
pour l'argent dans le court terme et le
laissait faire penser qu'elle pays où la
france est un pays qui a adopté le
modèle libéral financier sans l'avoir
jamais délibérément parmi ceux qui se
sont le moins le mois écoulé je pense
qu'il ya par exemple tous les pays
d'amérique du sud la chine est l'exemple
même de la fusion du public et du privé
le
l'allemagne d'une certaine manière a su
le travail et faire travailler le public
et le privé et les états unis ont réussi
ça aussi également alors pourquoi ces
mesures doivent être prises parce que
sinon nous allons nous écrouler nous
allons perdre notre base et l'allemagne
surtout baisser le coût du travail vous
le savez je ne connais mais sur la
sphère du coût du travail comme tous les
étés d'invisibilité et même des membres
du gouvernement disent qu'à pas entre la
france et la main une différence de coût
du travail
tollé mais monsieur lellouche le déclare
voilà dans tous les journaux un peu
sérieux serre ce qui servent pas prendre
par la propagande de monsieur sarkozy
tout le monde reconnaît qu'il a pas
d'écart de coût du travail il y a juste
15 ans vingt ans d'investissements dans
la recherche développement remontée en
gamme dans la qualité et une stratégie
de répartition avec les pays hors zone
euro qui sont voisins qui sont les
anciens pays de l'est où on fait sous
traiter la met au garde les fonctions et
grandes fonctions de production et
d'assemblage son territoire de dirigisme
dernière question ça c'est de la
politique voyez c'est ça le dirigisme
c'est que l'état se met à diriger oui
parce que l'économie elle même est
incapable de se sauver elle en est
incapable
c'est ça que je voulais dire monsieur
vous avez vous avez sur votre gauche un
candidat qui semble mieux enfin avoir
plus l'attention de nos ouvriers
l'électorat populaire que vous c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui vient de parler
qui dit qui est des cas de nouveau
refusé de participer à un gouvernement
hollandais ou qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
j'ai pensé sur le coup que ça serait
plutôt une de vos expressions pendant la
campagne de la primaire
vous pouvez en échange mais pas mon
expression parce que je respecte les
personnes mais l'expression hollande dre
ou c'est à dire j'ai sous-entend que si
force contre lens gagne l'élection
présidentielle sa priorité sera de
ramener le déficit public à 3 % en 2013
et à 0 % à l'horizon 2017 est ce que
vous pensez que vous êtes à l'aise avec
cet objectif avec les concessions et les
conséquences sociales qui pourrait
entraîner d'abord quel est l'objectif
désendetter le pays
oui si vous passez votre temps à
rembourser les dettes
on a dans sa sphère du peuple étaient
remisés eux c'est compatible avec la
politique industrielle que vouloir une
chose et je reprends rembourser ses
dettes c'est bien mais ça ne fait pas un
projet pour un pays tu parles en vous
remboursez vos dettes vous avez tous les
autres pays qui investissent donc comme
on fait il ya deux manières soit en
monétique
c'est à dire qu'on fait la planche à
billet n'était pas une mauvaise solution
ce qu'ont fait les américains ce que
font les anglais ça évite que soit la
sueur des contribuables qui rembourse
c'est notre proposition je vous le
signale c'est ça c'est pas ça c'est pas
hollande ray ou papandréou c'est le
contraire de madame merkel qu'elle a
réussi à imposer avec le soutien de
monsieur sarkozy à la grèce donc ce
n'est pas notre choix donc vouloir mêler
et mélanger monsieur papandréou et
monsieur hollande est donc une attaque
personnelle déplacer bien
ensuite s'agissant des conséquences
sociales vous parlez de quoi rétablir
nos comptes publics mais nous en avons
déjà pour investir et pour pouvoir
réindustrialiser le pays
assurer la transition écologique et même
le programme de jean luc mélenchon que
j'approuve dans certains de ses aspects
contient des éléments qui renvoie à
notre propre programme
mais il faut bien financer nous allons
le faire comment il ya deux solutions la
soie ou diminuer les dépenses et la haye
les conséquences sociales difficiles
c'est ce que fait la droite soit vous
augmentez les impôts et c'est notre
proposition comme celle de jean noël à
l'argent voilà ce que nous proposons
merci ça me hante aussi alors la
situation serait de toute façon
difficile quel que soit le vainqueur à
l'elysée est ce que vous redoutez des
vagues de licenciements après la
présidentielle comme l'a annoncé
françois chérèque qui le tient de
patrons et de drh ou penser que la ja
nous sommes informés des risques dans de
nombreux plans sociaux sont aujourd'hui
dissimulés dans la tente du résultat
électoral et interviendront dans la
foulée du résultat à l'élection
présidentielle et si françois chérèque
le dic est un homme sérieux c'est qu'il
a d'excellentes raisons de pouvoir le
dire très bien alors perrine tarneaud
donc va nous rejoindre on célèbre avec
vous le printemps des poètes avec aragon
bien sûr je disais qui vous a inspiré
pour votre mouvement que vous avez créé
a aidé à kérou h
c'est lui qui croyait au ciel
c'est lui qui n'y croyaient pas lincourt
et l'autre à dl le bretagne ou du jura
les framboises ou mirabel le grillon
rechantera la rose et le réséda un poème
de louis aragon un appel à la résistance
face à l'occupation nazie en 1942 un son
pour nous
du peuple face à l'adversité les
personnes les résistants auquel il est
dédié donc quelle il rend hommage dont
il exalte le sacrifice sont vous donne
la clé du poème il y a d'estienne
d'orves gaulliste et catholique
il y a gabriel péri communiste est donc
celui qui ne croit pas au ciel comme
deal poèmes vous avez gilbert brute
jeune résistant catholique de lyon
et puis guy môquet guy môquet jeune
résistant communiste fusillé a fusillé à
châteaubriant aujourd'hui on découvre
arnaud montebourg sensible à la poésie
alors la rose et le réséda c'est tout un
symbole qui l'a choisi pour le titre de
son mouvement d'idées fraîchement
inauguré un choix qui laisse sceptique
l'exécuteur testamentaire de l'oeuvre du
poète communiste
la difficulté c'est cette vouloir
transposer la lettre du poème dans la
situation historique qui est la nôtre de
l' enfer
un étendard à le brandir on va était au
début du 21e siècle ça me paraît douteux
la rose à la main alors qu'il effleure
certaines idées communistes
arnaud montebourg n'oubliera pas de
voter pour le voyage de hollande
un autre poème d'aragon le voyage ne
sais pas si vous le connaissez
perrine qui a inspiré bien des poèmes ou
six chefs doute le parallèle entre les
deux époques entre ce poème de 43 et
notre époque actuelle
vous faites ce parallèle où les listes
parce que nous sommes notre patrie est
en difficulté notre nation est en danger
économie de survie économique
la dureté des temps et herring une
population qui comme après la grande
crise de 1929 d'une partie d'entre elles
peut être pourrait s'en remettre à des
aventuriers extrémistes donc ou
aventurière extremities où est ce que je
veux dire
donc mieux vaut prévenir que guérir
n'attendons pas les drames et les
tragédies nationales pour sortir les
grands mots je crois qu aragon à a rendu
un hommage extraordinaire à l'unité de
la nation quand elle est en difficulté
l'unité nationale l'unité de la nation
ça veut dire qu'on aura besoin de tout
le monde qui va falloir se donner la
main laissant sociale bat déjà les
forces sociales et force économique pour
laquelle ceux par lequel d'arriver à
coopérer ce que je disais d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure en parlant d'intérêt
public intérêts privés tous les pays qui
ont réussi ce les pubs des pays dans la
crise et pays qui ont réussi à s'unir
donc il va falloir trouver des compromis
les forces sociales et les forces
politiques aussi les forces sociales et
économiques déjà après les forces
politiques ont pas demander l'impossible
puis d'ailleurs préfère l'ouverture vers
la droite je ne ne ce n'est pas l'idée
qui est qui et c'est d'abord de trouver
des compromis dans la société avec des
forces qui ont besoin de coopérer pour
réussir sans tarder et c'est ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
quand vous avez un drame social une
entreprise qui ferme vous avez
généralement la cgt qui fait des
propositions
le patronat tu essaies de travailler
avec les uns des lots finalement on se
donne la main sur le terrain donc la
politique est une espèce de
de théâtre un peu artificiel où on
s'engueule inutilement secteur donc oui
un peu sectaire pendant côte sur le
terrain tout le monde essaie de se
mettre d'accord essayons de retrouver
cet état d'esprit c'est l'esprit du haut
de la rose et du résident à est ce que
c'est ce que vous apprenez sur le talent
en ce moment concernant votre mouvement
je vais vous vouliez vous ouvrira
différentes sensibilités et ça m'a amusé
je vous avais rencontré celui qui mène
les royalistes en france passait pas les
partisans de ségolène royal 1 mais les
parties signataires ne lisez pas ce qui
est dans le journal ça peut être faux
dans plusieurs journaux
ben c'est encore pire si vous allez
rencontrer bertrand roiné côté cinéma
mais vu je ne savais pas je suis pour ma
part républicains et les royalistes qui
d'ailleurs monsieur renouveau avait
soutenu françois mitterrand à l'époque
donc ça devrait nous rappeler quelque
chose s'en mêle alors là j'en perds mon
latin en tout cas arnaud montebourg on a
envie de savoir aujourd'hui ce que vous
avez envie de faire après cette
présidentielle
armé de votre nouveau mouvement de vos
17% à la primaire socialiste quelles
sont vos ambitions de poste présidentiel
si bien sûr françois hollande
la graine cette élection je sais que
vous n'allez pas me croire mais je n'en
ai absolument aucune
aujourd'hui d'exprimer en mon for
intérieur
pour une raison simple c'est que je
considère être arrivé au bout de ce que
je voulais faire en politique c'est la
raison pour laquelle le après quinze
années de mandat à l'assemblée nationale
j'ai décidé de ne pas solliciter de
nouveau mandat de ne pas me représenter
comme pour rien en janvier le courriel
que mule qui arrivent non c'est pas ça
j'aurais pu faire le choix d'abandonner
le conseil général que je préside avec
passion et de maintenir ma candidature
aux femmes vous êtes candidat qu'après
avoir fait toute cette campagne des
primaires socialites maintenant cette
campagne présidentielle vous allez
renoncer à la politique après les mâles
des sages il dit que j'avais quand même
j'ai défendu des orientations politiques
je suis pour les mettre au pouvoir les
concrétiser
changer la vie des gens mais ça peut
passer par mille manières de le faire et
il comprit d'être président d'un conseil
général de gauche sous la gauche au
pouvoir
voyez donc je n'ai pas fait partie de
cette génération un peu sacrifié comme
on dit au parti socialiste une aja
vraiment accéder aux aires non ça fait
30 ans quand lionel jospin j'étais jeune
j'étais bon j'étais jeune et sans
expérience
et bien maintenant le temps a passé je
suis très content je suis donc je
voulais indique je n'ai pas de
candidature à exprimer je n'ai pas
d'ambitions particulières à formuler
je suis passionné ils disent tous les
chantiers quiz de voir les autres c'est
déjà pas mal
on va parler des autres on parle du rot
on parle de l'arrivée à matignon de
martine aubry voire du retour de laurent
fabius
ça ce sont des bonnes d'hypothèses coûté
j'en sais rien moi je suis simple retour
des éléphants
je suis assez surpris de toutes ces
spéculations
ces conjectures pour une raison simple
où ces hypothèses d'ailleurs assez
farfelue pour une raison simple laquelle
le tout à raison simple c'est que il
faut d'abord gagner
vous ne croyez pas vous mettez un peu la
charrue avant les boeufs le quintal sein
de la maison du roy que ces déplacés ce
qui serait partie déjà l'est pas mais je
trouve que c'est déplacé il faut
respecter le corps électoral suffrage
universel et je dis à tous ceux qui font
des probabilités que c'est parfaitement
à côté des desiderata on va vous
exprimer de la population rétaise
martine aubry vous pouvez exprimer
mais je n'ai pas eu de réunion et par
ailleurs mais pas de pénis pas
d'ambition pas d'opinion sur la dernière
partie de ces thèmes qui vous
intéressent
je ne sais vraiment pas en plus su dire
ça ne dépend ni de vous un nid de loi
donc ça n'a aucun intérêt
reid pour début janvier vous déclariez
que vous ne pas vous sentir lié par le
pacte entre le parti socialiste et
europe écologie les verts pour les
législatives est ce que c'est toujours
vrai mais je voudrais vous expliquer
peut-être le sens de cette intervention
de ma part et où des primaires qui ont
mobilisé trois millions de personnes 3
million deux cent mille personnes
c'est donc finalement les primaires qui
ont porté le candidat et les
rassemblements qui ont lieu à l'issue de
ces primaires sur des orientations
politiques
il le fait qu'ils aient eu un accord
entre françois hollande moi même qui est
permis d'ailleurs à françois hollande le
candidat est un sens du bourget
deuxième tome de huy de bâti en quelque
sorte une orientation politique qui dans
laquelle je me sens tout à fait avec mes
amis à qui mineo morel qui fut mon
directeur de campagne qui rédige le
discours important de françois hollande
et d'autres de me sentir tout à fait
heureux et à l'aise dans cette campagne
c'est parce que françois hollande a
opéré un rassemblement avec les idées
qui avaient surgi dans la prière d'âme
signé un accord lui aussi avec le 21 mai
vous voyez bien que les accords
partisans en deuxième rideau qui arrive
derrière n'ont pas la même force et la
même légitimité parce qu'ils ne serait
ce que pour une chose c'est que en ce
qui me concerne j'ai réalisé un demi
million de voix aux primaires je n'ai
jamais été consulté sur la teneur de cet
accord et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je le considère pour moi légèrement à
l'écart du processus de rassemblement
nécessaire qui est intervenue à l'issue
des est-ce que c'est aussi parce que les
nucléaire pèse beaucoup dans votre
département
mais nous le caër inéluctablement dès
lors que vous engager la transition
écologique et énergétique que vous
voulez vous débarrasser de la dépendance
à l'égard des hydrocarbures des énergies
fossiles du pétrole vous ne pourrez pas
en plus ouvrir le front du nucléaire
donc faudra choisir soit on fait
l'après-pétrole son frêle après les
voilà mais on peut faire les deux voilà
c'est la zone pour laquelle moi j'ai une
position assez pragmatique qui se
rapproche plutôt de l'esprit des verts
inspirée par nicolas hulot jean marc
jancovici est produite et beaucoup
d'autres qui tous pas pro nucléaire
c'est que les gens connaissent et ils
sont modérés les choses la question pour
terminer le bureau du sénat doit se
prononcer la semaine prochaine le 15
mars sur la demande de levée de
l'immunité parlementaire du sénateur
guérini et navarro est ce que vous
demandez au sénat de gauche d'accéder à
cette demande des magistrats mais c'est
inéluctable je considère que tout
citoyen futile sénateurs doit accéder
aux exigences de la justice françois
bayrou propose que le garde des sceaux
soit nommé par le parlement avec une
majorité amplifié c'est à dire avec les
voiles l'opposition est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
c'est une fonction politique qui n'est
pas objective que le garde des sceaux
mène une politique dont ils répondent
avec le gouvernement peut-être que nous
pourrions imaginer qu un procureur
spécial pour les affaires sensibles
puissent être désigné aux trois
cinquièmes
on peut imaginer par exemple que la
composition du conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
c'est la provision par exemple de
françois hollande soit composé de
personnalités incontestables aux 3 5e du
parlement
nous pouvons imaginer cette formule en
tout cas c'est pas celle qui nous donna
sarkozy ami lance en eux et donc ce
n'est pas une mauvaise idée en soi elle
me paraît être excessives s'agissant du
garde des sceaux vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous trouvez votre compte
dans le programme de françois hollande
sur le plan de la démondialisation il ne
propose pas lui la sixième république
est ce que vous allez me répondre à
l'appel de jean luc mélenchon le 18 mars
une marche pour la 6ème république à
paris place de la bastille oui ou non
nos mondes bonne et je crois que j'irai
peut-être ses derniers je ne savais pas
que cela marche pour la 6ème république
à la pj le capitaine saluer parce que
c'est une bonne idée la 6ème république
vous voyez et d'ailleurs je trouve
françois hollande là d'une certaine
manière a bien avancé sur les
propositions dans son discours de dijon
samedi dernier c'est la 6ème république
en pièces détachées mais on peut dire
qu'il ya surtout il a surtout dit qu'il
fallait respecter à la lettre les
institutions de la vème oui mais ça ça
veut rien dire parce que les
institutions les un site non mais ça
veut rien dire au sens où c'est la
pratique qui imprime beaucoup c'est ça
qu'il veut dire mais il a quand même
proposé un sacré nombre de réformes
il peut le reconnaître allons beaucoup
sont contenues dans le programme early 2
jean luc mélenchon j'irai peut-être mais
jean-luc mélenchon pour la 6e' me
dérangerait vraiment pas au contraire
lui ça sans doute que ça l'arrangerait
sans doute merci perrine merci monsieur
montebourg la semaine prochaine c'est
bruno le maire le ministre de
l'agriculture qui sera l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir à bientôt
très vite